Let's go to...I don't know, the 830
area code. I don't think we've ever taken a call from 830
Whose...Who's there at 830
what's on your mind today?
"Hi...um...David. I was just wondering
...um what books would you recommend
for a fellow political junkie
um...to like get started
...like your top 5 books that you would recommend."
Oh man...that is so tough! I could...I mean...what
Can you be more specific...what are you looking to learn I guess but
politics is just such a general thing you know.
"Like...maybe...political philosophy,
economics...just
something like that maybe?"
Oh man...with economics I would recommend starting with
a lot of the key books from sort of rational,
traditional economics to understand that
foundation, and then move on to
behavioural economics and other economic theory
so you could start with everything from
you know, "The Wealth of Nations" (by Adam Smith) to something like
uh...not that I want to pitch his books but Thomas Sowell's
book "Basic Economics" which gives us like a standard
sort of conservative, rational economic approach
then, pull out something like Richard Wolff
my former professor and economist
Richard Wolff's book "Neoclassical v Marxist Economics"
(Actual title: Economics: Marxian versus Neoclassical [1987])
To start understanding
the difference...maybe you would read some Marx.
uh...I would check out Angus Deaton's recent book
uh...the name of which escapes me
(probably "The Great Escape" [2013]) but it's about
uh...inequality
fantastic book. I would read Daniel Kahneman's
"Thinking, Fast and Slow" [2011] and some of Dan Ariely's books
to understand how real world
economics is not this hypothetical
uh...um...
rational economics. So I don't know, there's six or seven books
for you to start with I guess.
"Well...thanks David. I really appreciate all the list."
Alright. Thank you so much I'll let you get back to...sounds like
a lot is going on in the background there...so I'll let you get back to that
seems like a really, really busy day
uh...over there!